the foundation series is one of the most
influential science fiction series of
all time
written by Isaac Asimov the first novel
titled foundation was published in 1951
foundation was originally published as
four short stories the fifth story which
was published later became the first
segment of book 1 ozma had wanted to
write a short story about a slowly
declining Galactic Empire based on the
fall of Rome this idea grew into a story
depicting the fall of the first Galactic
Empire and the rise of the second in the
distant future humankind has spread out
to 25 million different planets the
Galactic Empire has ruled for the past
twelve thousand years in that twelve
thousand years the Empire has existed in
peace and prosperity ever expanding the
origin of humanity is lost to time
at the start of the series the capital
of the Galactic Empire is on the planet
Trent or which is entirely encased by
technology the people of Trent or rarely
see the Sun and they have special rooms
which simulate sunlight Harry Selden who
spent his life developing a branch of
mathematics known as psychohistory
has predicted the fall of the Galactic
Empire psychohistory is a concept of
mathematical sociology and makes use of
the laws of mass action to predict the
future on a large scale harry sees that
the collapse of the empire is imminent
he predicts a Dark Age expanding across
the Milky Way that will last for thirty
thousand years before the second great
empire arises however according to his
calculation there is a way to limit
these dark ages to just a single
millennium to ensure this outcome
Harry Selden creates the foundation with
the permission of the Emperor a colony
is formed on the planet terminus and
they begin work on the encyclopedia
Galactica
to record the history of the Empire and
preserve and expand humanity's
collective knowledge terminus is a bleak
planet on the edge of the galaxy but it
is the last hope for the future the
colony is made up of talented engineers
and artisans the foundation soon finds
itself at the mercy of the corrupt
warlords of the four kingdoms who have
arisen in the wake of the receding
Empire in the beginning
according to Selden it was the
encyclopedia that somehow would prevent
the 30,000 year interregnum but after 50
years a holographic video of Selden
reveals to the encyclopedist of Trant or
that it was a farce the true purpose of
the foundation is actually to form the
center of the second Galactic Empire
Harry had to manipulate events in these
ways in order for his plan to work and
he could not even tell the people of
Trent or everything he knew less he
ruined his careful outlining the novel
is split into five segments the first
segment is called the psycho historians
and it deals with Harry Selden and his
subtle manipulation of the Committee of
Public Safety into helping him establish
the colony on terminus the second part
is called the encyclopedist it deals
with the growing unrest of the colonists
who do not work on the encyclopedia it
is in this segment that the foundation
experiences its first crisis throughout
the segments of the first book the
foundation deals with several different
crises separated by decades which had
been predicted by Harry Selden it is
also in this segment that the true
purpose of the foundation as the seed of
the new empire is revealed by the third
segment titled Mayer's 80 years have
passed since the start of the foundation
the second crisis is beginning an
acronym one of the four kingdoms that
arose is planning to attack the
foundation the foundation is delivered
from the crisis when mayor Hardin uses
the religion they have created and
thrust upon the people of an actor Aeon
to turn the people of an Akron against
its own government in another video the
hologram of Harry Selden reveals that
this was also intended the fourth
segment is called the traitors it takes
place a hundred and fifty-five years
after the start of the foundation it
deals with trader linn-mar pinettes who
has been sent by the foundation to
bargain with the elders of the planet s
Cohn after a fellow trader has been
arrested and sentenced to death after
attempting to sell illegal goods the
final segment of the book takes place
several years after the traders and is
called the merchant Prince's the
foundation has become very powerful they
have subdued and subjugated the
neighboring four kingdoms and have
expanded their technological and
commercial empire throughout many
stellar systems Harry Selden knew he was
dying at the beginning of the book the
foundation was his legacy thanks to his
complex discipline of psychohistory
he was able to predict the behavior of
the masses over time and he timed it
perfectly
leaving future generations instructions
in order to avoid thousands of years of
the dark ages foundation is not only
science fiction it is political fiction
foundation like dune also explores how
people can be manipulated through
religion character development is not
the focus here there are large amounts
of technical and scientific details and
many schemes and plots within plots the
book centers around the leaders of and
the people of the foundation itself
mostly on the planet terminus throughout
the book the foundation threatens
manipulates and employs
divide-and-conquer tactics to fight
against those who would attempt to seize
their resources interestingly enough
this is accomplished all without
violence violence is the last refuge of
the incompetent
the foundation is built around this
mantra it is in fact the main theme of
the entire book knowledge when used
correctly is the far better weapon
foundation is a pillar of science
fiction and a must read for all those
who love the genre the foundation series
has seven books dealing with the fall of
the old Empire and the rise of the new
one the final book in the series was
published thirty-five years after the
original was published the novels
spanned over the course of many
centuries and create the blueprint for
all Galactic Empire seen in science
fiction since
[Music]
you